[Applause]  what are you any words of wisdom what  about for all the other kids trying to  learn how to ride their bike can you say  anything to them this is Anthony Anthony  is 24 years old and has autism this is  Anthony's next challenge it's a business  a delivery service  Anthony's excited about doing deliveries  because he loves going out meeting new  people and crossing things off his list  we are in New York but I flew in from  Hong Kong  yesterday evening for Thanksgiving  that's right  big surprise big surprise and this is  what this is what I give I give an  expression of care every day to each  child to help him realize that he is  unique I end the program by saying  you've made this day a special day by  just your being you there's no person in  the whole world like you and I like you  just the way you are  all eyes that stars last gleaming whose  broad stripes and bright stars through  the perilous fight o the ramparts we  watched were so gallantly streaming  [Music]